here to respond is retired Brigadier
General Robert Spaulding and Lieutenant
Colonel James Kerr Fano from the
Heritage Foundation James you believe
that Bolton was actually promoting
Trump's america-first policies but if
that was the case why is he going well
first of all well I'm my hearts broken
here and this is like the captain and
Tennille break enough I mean I love the
yin the yang of Bolton and Trump I
thought that dynamism work actually
worked really well but the first point
is is let's remember before it was the
axis of adults right it was Kelly mattis
Tillerson and HR they kept the president
from doing all these crazy things all
those guys are completely gone our
foreign policy is exactly the same it'll
now the Bolton's gone it'll be exactly
the same that's because it's Trump's
foreign policy and there although it
didn't work out and I'm sad about that
there were things that Bolton really did
help with Nancy after pulling out of INF
he was great on China by the way Bolton
my China is fabulous awesome so we're
like so nautical on that issue that's
fine with Matt really strong on Briggs
it really helped push out with Boris
Johnson on breakfast so there were a lot
of areas where he held but you think I'm
saying though general like that when
this news broke it didn't surprise any
of us but the media acted like pence
resigned or something it was it was wild
to see it's chaos you were there with
McMaster you were at the National
Security Council with McMaster was there
so what do you say about all this first
of all the president inherited chaos
we've had decades of really poor foreign
policy not thinking about what's going
on with China basing basically
intervening just about everywhere and
the president president said stop we're
gonna actually do something more like
out of Eisenhower's playbook we're gonna
husband our resources we're gonna
strengthen the economy we're gonna work
on the industrial base we're gonna get
prepared for this economic and
technological competition with the
Chinese and we're gonna stop being
everywhere except the national security
establishment said no we want to be
there not opposed to him almost every
doubt of the way every step of the way
you know I'd like to say nice thing
about HR people forget HR had a good
year
he put a good strategy on table he took
what was him said no no and he put it on
paper and Trump's still following that
strategy
I met him he's a very nice I mean this
is not personal but this is about the
President's agenda he was elected as a
repudiation of both Obama and Bush on
foreign policy I'm sorry and a lot of
people of Bush friends of mine I love
them dearly I was a big supporter of the
Iraq war I think it was a colossal
mistake Afghanistan we got to get out of
Afghanistan a war in 19 years
I'm sorry you think we should still be
there with no I you know we'll say the
the the point about you know HR leaving
who I thought did a good job for the
time that he was there and for Bolton
but your point is right there not moving
fast enough for this president he was
president has a plan and he wants
results and if it's not me it's not that
he's a nice guy you know we saw the
other thing he calls HR now and talks to
him called John no brakes but he's fine
with that he's riding with opposing
views people say he's not he thrives and
spin part on hearing from lots of inputs
but then he makes a decision when he
feels undermined afterward people are
leaking to the media and you know who
you are that's what he doesn't like I
want to play for something from Rand
Paul this is what he said today about
threats
perhaps diminished around the world with
Bolton's departure watch I think the
threat of war around the world is
greatly diminished with Bolton out of
the White House I think he had a naive
point of view for the world that we
should topple regime's everywhere and
Institute you know democratic
governments and we would make the world
perfect or we make the world in our
image and frankly just doesn't work that
way see here's what I disagree
it's Trump's policy not Bolton's Trump
doesn't want to fight useless work he
wasn't hey Bolton wasn't gonna launch a
thermonuclear weapon is this a
president's decision and the president
made that point several times over the
last several months when Bolton was
there and so I want to talk now about
what Jim Acosta said and scolding Steve
minutia
today watch I think we have it is this a
national security team MS absolutely not
that's the most ridiculous question I've
ever heard the national security team
which is what you asked consists of the
national security the Secretary of
Defense the Secretary of State myself
the chief oh yeah so he listed all
people in the national security
apparatus totally undermining what the
media was trying to do with this staff
departure which is long in the coming
general well I think that you know so
back in 2014 we looked at what was going
on with what was happening at China
everything that was going on with all
these interventionist wars that were
going on across and we realized that we
needed to be focused on building the
country building our strength and the
president it was it was strange because
2016 he starts talking about investing
in the country building the strength
taking care of the American people and
was everything that we had been looking
at in the Pentagon so he he has this
kind of sixth sense of where we need to
go with the strategy I have to say and
the people of the country James if I
think every poll shows this they don't
think it's 1994 anymore it's not 2003
anymore we're 20 trillion dollars in
debt and yet we have folks you know
former bush people and they're running
website it's like oh we've got to put
more troops in Afghanistan I heard that
the other night I think it might have
been on this network
I must fell over I said are you kidding
me those days are gone they're never
coming back I've heard everything said
we should take him out and then like a
week later they say what we need to put
him back in well cuz whatever Trump
wants they want the opposite but see
there's the disconnect between
Washington the American people watch it
and focuses on this process and you hear
all those comments whether on the
comment we don't like we don't like his
style points what Americans look at is
he delivering and they like that he's
delivering all right I got one more
thing I want to play if we can guys I
want to play this Condoleezza Rice was
on CBS this morning she was doing the
round she's booked out and so she gave a
compunctious kind of fun interviews well
this is one I think that the president
might have missed this particular clip
let's watch I've seen the return of what
I've called The Four Horsemen of the
Apocalypse populism I'll say nativism
not national not nationalism
isolationism and protectionism we did
that before it was the period between
World War 1 and World War 2 led to a
Great Depression it led to war okay
general the great to provoke so coming I
guess if we don't put a hundred thousand
well the great depressions here it's
been here actually since 2001 when
the WTO we lost seventy thousand over
seventy thousand factories 3.4 million
manufacturing jobs we can't even make
circuit boards for f-35s that's how
that's how poor our industrial base is
becoming did that happen general when
did saina come under the WTO 2001 yeah
we got it alright guys thank you very
much